how many solutions does the following
system of linear equations have and i
have my system right over here there's a
couple of ways to think about it one way
is to think about them graphically and
think about well are they the same line
in which case they would have an
infinite number of solutions are they
parallel in which case they never
intersect you'd have no solutions or do
they intersect exactly one place in case
you would have one solution but instead
we're going to do this algebraically so
let's try to actually just solve the
system and see what we get
so
the first equation i'm going to leave
that unchanged 5x minus 9y
is equal to is equal to the 16.
now this second equation right over here
let's say i want to cancel out the x
terms so let me multiply the second
equation by negative 1. so i have a
negative 5x that i can cancel out with
the 5x so if i multiply the second
equation by negative 1 i'm going to have
negative 5x
plus 9y
plus 9y
is equal to negative 36
negative 36. now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to add the left side of the
equations and the right sides of the
equations to get a new equation
so 5x minus 5x well that's going to be 0
negative 9y plus 9y well that's going to
be 0 again i don't even have to write it
it's just going to be 0 on the left hand
side
and on the right hand side i'm going to
have 16 minus 36 of negative 20.
so now i'm left with the somewhat
bizarre looking equation that says that
0 is equal to negative 20.
now one way you might say well how does
this make any sense and the way to think
about it is well are there any x y
values for which is 0 is going to be
equal to negative 20
well no 0 is never going to be equal to
negative 20. and so it doesn't matter
what x y values so you can never find an
x
or x y pair that's going to make 0 equal
to negative 20. in fact the x's and y's
have disappeared from this equation
there's no way that this is going to be
true so we have no
we have no solutions now if you were to
plot these if you were to plot each of
these lines you would see that they are
parallel lines and that's why
they have the same slope different
y-intercepts and that's why we have no
solutions they don't intersect
let's do another one of these this is
this is fun
all right how many solutions does the
following system of linear equations
have
so let's do the same thing i'm going to
keep the first equation the same
negative 6x
plus 4y
is equal to 2. and the second equation
let me just see if i can cancel out the
x term so if i have a negative 6x if i
multiply this by 2 i'm going to have a
positive 6x
so i can let's see i'm going to multiply
this whole equation both sides of it by
2.
so i'm going to have 6x 3x times 2 is 6x
negative 2y times 2 is negative
4y
and that is going to be equal to
negative 2.
now let's do the same thing let's add
the left sides and let's add the right
sides so negative 6x plus 6x well that's
going to be 0.
4y minus 4y that's 0. we just have a
zero on the left hand side now on the
right hand side we have two plus
negative two well that's zero so this is
a little bit different it still looks a
little bit bizarre zero equals zero last
time we had zero is equal to we had what
zero is equal to negative 20. now we
have zero equals zero
so one way to think about it is even
though the x's and y's are no longer in
this equation we say well what x y pairs
is it going to be true for
z that is going to make it true that
zero is equal to zero
well this is going to be true no matter
what x and y are in fact x and y are not
involved in this equation anymore 0 is
always going to be equal to 0. so this
is going to have and infinitely this is
going to have infinitely
many solutions here and that's because
these are the same lines they just look
a little bit different algebraically but
if you scale one of them in the right
way in fact if you just multiply both
sides of this one the second one by
negative two you're going to get the top
one and so they actually represent the
exact same lines you have an infinitely
many solutions
all right
when trying to find the solution to the
following system of linear equations
yvonne takes several correct steps that
lead to the equation negative 5 is equal
to 20.
how many solutions does the system of
linear equations have i don't even have
to look at the system right over here
the fact that she got the statement that
can never be true negative 5 is never
going to be equal to 20 tells us that
she has no solutions and once again if
you were to plot these graphically you
would see that these are parallel lines
that's why they have no solutions they
never intersect there's no xy pair that
satisfies both of these constraints
let's do let's do a couple more of these
when trying to find the solution to the
following system of linear equations
albus takes several correct steps that
lead to the equation five y is equal to
negative five
and they say how many solutions does
this system of linear equations have
well five y equals negative five we
could divide both sides by five and we
get y is equal to negative one
and then if you substitute back in y is
equal to negative one if you did it in
this first equation if y is equal to
negative one all of this
becomes positive two you can subtract 2
from both sides and you get 5
x
is equal to
4 or you would get what x is equal to 4
fifths or if you put negative 1 over
here you would get 5x minus 3
is equal to one you could add three to
both sides and you get five x equals
four again x is equal to four fifths so
you have exactly one solution you would
have x is equal to four fifths
y is equal to
negative one let's do one more
when trying to find the solution of the
following system of linear equations
levon takes several correct steps that
lead to the equation zero equals zero so
once again i don't even need to look at
this over here zero equals zero is
always going to be true so this is going
to happen infinitely this is going to be
an infinitely
many
solutions